the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
uh so I'll be sitting down here and
showing you a whole lot of really cool
of videos on YouTube and battlecode
players that I've programmed especially
for tonight so here we go what's you
know what's the point here that the
point here is to talk about the things
that have been done before in swarm and
thinking about swarm so let's let's go
straight to a YouTube video and and look
at this animation so you can see here
there will be these these birds that are
following the green blob and they avoid
the red blob and what they're trying to
do is match one another's direction try
to get a certain distance from the other
birds and try to avoid obstacles and so
you can see how the combination of a few
simple rules can create a behavior
that's sort of complicated looking or a
behavior that somewhat fluid whereas if
you would like manually tried to get
them all to go in the same direction you
know it might have looked somewhat more
rigid and they might not have been able
to handle things like obstacles so let's
look at another video of how this is
done in nature now this is a massive
number of birds I think in the video
description it says this is 300,000
birds wow it's so pretty how it
undulates and and smooshes around here's
another view of the same thing I think
they'll all take off in the distance
look at how pretty that is and you know
they all sort of do it at once but
there's certainly nobody in control what
a pretty ah you gotta love pictures of
nature in the evening in a lecture hall
we're about as far from nature's people
can get my goodness that's so pleasing
when are they going to show the birds
I'm referring to the birds that aren't
in the water the birds in the air yeah
so what we want to do today is just talk
about the things that are recognized as
elements of swarm behavior and then
we'll show how like our robots can do
much better than the enemy robe
it's if we do it right look at this it's
almost like two separate swarms in
certain areas and it's an interesting
problem to say like at what point is it
possible to split into two swarms
because maybe one of them got too far
from the other or maybe it's just too
gosh darn big or maybe you know one half
of them are Democrats and I have
Republicans like there are a lot of
reasons that they that they might want
to split into parts so we'll talk about
that too next we'll talk about crowds I
mean this is a thing that you deal with
every day when you go to eat battlecode
lecture dinner like you come up here and
there's like people trying to get to
food and I guess the food is there now
this is a bad example because these guys
are just going to like walk through one
another the goal is like trying to get
them to anticipate you know who isn't
going to be in the way and deform lanes
that was that was a the problem that
these guys were trying to address and I
guess I guess nowadays it's becoming
popular to post your like thesis
material online and animated in 3d I
don't see why this is animated 3d you
could just show the same thing with like
a two-dimensional map now here there
you're going to see like ripples form
and that's like the expectation path and
so a small perturbation in the position
of someone is amplified in to like avoid
this lame and and hear that he shows it
again with some lines he does it with
more people because you know every
computer scientist knows that more is
better especially when it comes to
simulations and so he's got like he
shows like a bunch of them and and how
these guys going up there and those guys
are doing then there and they sort of
make this vortex and I think oh yeah I
remember this is this really silly the
end of this video you're not going to
see it coming at all like you you're
thinking all right where can he go from
here he can show like so there's their
model and there's some alternative
models showing that their model is like
a lot better because people aren't
bunching up so there's these high gear
slow and high distance models which
basically you know the guys are just
avoiding one another but in their model
they're sort of creating a density field
for expected position they have like I
think this is supposed to be simulating
like armies I guess they want a job at
Pixar or whatever and so they
sort of put this one in here they're
like oh look at how realistic your
armies will look if people at the back
move ten times as fast and then like
another army is over here because just
like I said you know these computer
science people like nothing more than to
have a lot of things I once saw a
simulation it was all this was crazy it
was a simulation of like neutronics so
this is like a college campus I mean you
can really tell that you know where this
guy is coming from movies campus and
it's like people are coming from certain
doors and going to others and I think
the next shot he'll show the paths of
these people showing that they're not
like bumping into each other that much
and that they're kind of straightish
paths which is supposed to be very
impressive but put back to my other
story i was watching like a neutronic
simulation and have like two billion
particles in it that we're all in like a
lattice okay I'm going to pause this
here when it gets to the city I mean my
goodness how a more complete do you need
once you've seen it you've kind of seen
it but anyway this 2 billion particle
lattice which took like 10 hours on a
giant supercomputer to do this like
simulation of damage from radiation from
like high-energy particle radiation and
and the final result the final result of
this massive simulation that I saw was
like it was to show that like this one
incoming particle had like ricocheted in
a couple of ways and and the diagram of
this final result from this giant
computation which was like the very end
of his presentation because for some
reason people don't like to show the
graphics first they like to tell you all
the words first then in case you show me
this thing and it's like one little
little it's like a little hook or
something it was really stupid looking
oh my goodness can't believe it but no
this guy's final result is going to be
much more exciting so he's got these
people and he's like well this isn't
realistic in a real city there are cars
so you got an only walk on the
crosswalks and there's like you got to
avoid certain things and you know maybe
you form lanes of traffic on these
crosswalks kind of automatically oh now
he's getting more he's like okay I've
got too much time on my hands I better I
better implement stoplights but it's
still not that realistic because what if
people get hit by cars like there are no
cars to hit people or to almost hit them
or just scare them and get them to jump
out of the way so you know now we've got
like a 3d flyover because the only thing
cooler than having a 3d environment
is a slow pan and zoom so that's what
that's what he's sort of doing here he
puts the cars in obviously he has
excellent taste all the cars are from
1970 and like I guess there's jaywalking
oh right this is like this is like a
chemical evacuation or something so like
all these people are covered in yellow
stuff and they're like running away and
that's supposed to be like really useful
for planning evacuations and such yeah
and everybody else is just like ah ok
I'm going to worry about that three two
one now and then like the other people
start running away too they have like
really bad reaction time and then and
then this is like people are walking in
the street and how it's messing up
traffic and it's like wow this is this
traffic is almost as bad as New York
city traffic almost almost as bad and
then this I mean what else can this guy
do after he's done this many things well
the last thing that he has his aliens so
there you go just to show that everybody
likes to have a little bit of fun with
padding and navigation so let's uh let's
talk a little bit about the things that
we saw in those videos and how they
apply to battle code so there's a whole
question of centralized versus
decentralized control and then the ones
that we saw they weren't centralized so
i'm going to show you examples in battle
code of both of those now if it's you
know those those can have impacts on
whether there's a radio attack possible
whether you know your your strategy is
going to be vulnerable to that whether
it's like a map dependent strategy
because maybe on a centralized
controller works really well if it's a
tiny map but maybe if it's a huge map
you've got to start having multiple
swarms that are independent and talking
about distributing information is
another is another thing to worry about
so let's let's consider that in the
boyds model which is supposed to sound
like birds if you have a Brooklyn accent
they consider several aspects for
computing the next position for each
actor in the swarm the separation of
each one to its neighbors
the the pushing together of each one
which they call cohesion because the
smarter you sound the more PhD money and
grant money you can make they caught
they talked about alignment so that
everybody's facing the same direction
that's that's somewhat different this
year than it has been in past battlecode
years and they are and then I guess they
don't talk too much about it but they
consider the later effects of group
splitting and and Lane creation which we
which we saw today so let's see here I
showed some examples of these things
alignment this year is worth noting that
there's there used to be a method call
where you could take the robot info and
do dot direction you could get the road
you could get the direction of any robot
that you can see now in this year's
battle code there's no direction so what
are you going to do so let's uh let's
see here I mean you can get the
distances for separation and cohesion I
mean these are just in a fancy way of
just saying there's like a spring
between you and the others and this
one's you know just saying that you're
headed the right way I mean there's
there's really almost nothing
complicated to it and we're going to
we're going to end up seeing some pretty
neat-looking behavior from very simple
rules so yeah let's makes let's talk
about how you're going to know that
you're facing the right direction I mean
you could you could check all the
neighbors let's see your face face the
right direction you could check all the
neighbors against all the other ones so
you'd be like checking to see if robot
ID number 97 was from this position and
then that one and then you would like
try to find where he was and correlate
that and get the direction and then take
an average for all the robots that you
can see they'll be really
computationally expensive another option
is to say all right take average of all
Allied robots or all within a range and
then see how that average moves so
that's like an implicit direction for
the group of the group of Allied robots
and then and then an individual robot by
doing that could see where all of them
are another option is just to radio
broadcast so that somebody somewhere is
deciding what direct
ago or maybe all of them vote on the
direction that they want to go because
maybe some of them are close to enemies
and other ones are standing on mines and
maybe they want to you know put it up to
a vote so that they can wait for 50
turns before finding out you know when
which direction they're going to go and
end up going in the wrong direction
anyway or they could have a recount and
anything you know it could be it could
be really fun you could do like a whole
political simulation so here's here are
some considerations when you when you're
talking about central control versus the
group mind where the central controller
you know you'd need a leader and so
leader leaders have to have electrons
elections and they also can die and
sometimes they get lost so those are
things to worry about when you have a
leader that means that the headquarters
is a good choice and so if you can do
all of your computations in one place I
mean that's that's much more efficient
imagine if you had to I mean every robot
has all the same information but if all
of them make the decisions then they all
have to do a lot of thinking and in this
game you know if you fit if you use a
10,000 bytecodes each of those robots is
going to have twice the power upkeep
it's going to be pretty significant so
you could have the leader broadcast the
broadcast all kinds of things and later
on we're going to talk about some more
little details of what the leader can
broadcast besides just what direction
you're going in that can really save you
a lot of trouble if you have a group
mind it's it's a little different you
know you can have a higher a better
sight range which is to say that in
previous years you were limited to just
one robot sight range so having a group
mind sort of gave you more access to the
edges of your cloud I and you could also
make it so that the front guys are
leading should be really useful so that
you could you could have them be the
first ones to know it is here it's not
so important but in in like a real flock
of birds or something you might develop
after this it would be you can also
broadcast the enemy locations in a group
line there's no reason why a group mind
can't use broadcast this is a question
of whether you expect to receive
something from a single entity or
whether you expect to integrate a bunch
of broadcast from a lot of entities
broadcasting is becoming cheaper and
cheaper now that the read cost has been
decreased from 0 point 0 12.00 3 we've
also increased the number of channels in
the latest release so that your
broadcasts are more secure against radio
attacks at least those spamming attacks
it is worth mentioning that you should
be moving your your channel somehow you
know come up with your own algorithm for
shifting the channel that you're using
something for example that uses the
clock round number so that you could
always be looking in a different place
and the enemy won't locate which
channels you're using on the radio which
is to say which which frequencies so you
might also want some some other some
other features so these Boyd's things
with their separation and and such you
know what other what other features do
you want that aren't in Boyd so you
might want some in and out motion so
that some guys so that everybody takes a
uniform amount of damage you know you
might want some cycling behavior you
might want to heal the week by going
back to the med bays you might want to
apply shields at the shield generators
those are encampments that you can build
and you might want to you know you might
want to make sure that each robot knows
the size of the pack if each one only
has so much information then especially
about the enemy you know then they need
to be able to get around I mean this
year is not so much of a problem again
so let's see here there's sort of
there's sort of an interesting trade-off
here when you think about the density of
a group but we're doing too much talking
and not enough watching let's watch
let's watch an example so I have some
players here and swarm 1 i'm just going
to pick any old map here let's go to
chunky chunky is a map i made which has
just these big chunks of minds so here
you can see I've got my swarm one player
it's very simple it's quite close to the
other players that I showed you it's not
that exciting because the robots are
just sort of they rush out one another
you know they come together in the
middle they do you know they just go
toward one another there's not that much
sort of swarm like behavior and when
they come together they're not really
doing anything that intelligent like at
this at this moment neither side is is
real
b is really being that smart about what
to do with the other here I'm going to
do it slightly differently I'm going to
have the robots instead of just choosing
a rally point at random at the very
beginning of the game and having each
robot computed individually i'm hearing
the swarm 1 i'm going to show how in
swarm to just this code we've included
the ability for the headquarters to tell
the robots where to go so you can see
let's see here let's change the font
size so that you can see what I'm saying
and follow along in the code font 16 who
pay the headquarter code here is what
the headquarters is doing so it does
some spawning soldiers I've got a nice
code documentation here it moves the
rally point from time to time which is
to say that at round greater than 500 it
just sets the rally point to the enemy
headquarters location and it messages
allies about where to go so first it
gets the channel from my function called
get channel and when I do that I say
that if I'm team if I'm Team B I'm going
to have this multiplier and if I'm team
hey I'm going to have this multiplier so
that when I calculate the channel I do
the clock round number times the
multiplier modulo the game constants
broadcast max channels so that means
that the channel that I'm broadcasting
on is continually rotating but because
it's just based on my team and the clock
round number that means that every robot
can still read off that channel still
knows where to look for that channel and
rotating frequencies is actually a
common practice in modern military
communications after all I might have it
might not have occurred to you that in
the modern military they don't just like
you know flip open their cell phones and
then say you know hey hey general Saxony
do you want to sort of attack tonight
and the general goes yeah maybe I might
I'm not sure maybe i'll send you an
email like they often use radio because
there's like not internet connection out
there in the middle of nowhere so and
they and they have these rotating radio
frequencies so yeah that's a good thing
that you'll have so once you've got the
channel you need to have a message
so here I've wrote the mess I've written
the message builder that converts same
application to an integer so you can see
that function here all i do is i
multiply the x value by a thousand and I
add the Y value so then both x and y
values are included finally on the
unpacking side I use this function to
turn the integer back into a map
location it makes life easier so then at
the robot side you can see the result so
we're going to we're going to show swarm
one vs swarm to swarm to has two
advantages so here's swarm to is in blue
and swarm to has two advantages the
first of which is that it it receives
the messages from the headquarters so
it'll go attack at around 500 rather
than the round that these guys are
attacking which is around 200 so I guess
it has sort of an advantage there and
second advantage is it doesn't defuse
mines in combat you know some of you may
be of familiar with World of Warcraft or
those type games defusing mines in
combat is like looting in combat it's
definitely a no note you don't want to
do that that's that's not how to be a
team player and you can see the result
is that just because you aren't defusing
mines in combat where the other team was
you have you end up with almost your
whole army remaining what a huge
difference and then quickly at round
five hundred you can see that these guys
are successfully receiving a goal and
here in size size point 0001 font you
can see that it knows its current
location and it has a goal location
which has been broadcast from this guy
so now you can see a little example but
that's nuts not as exciting as it might
be let's consider adding some distance
tolerance in go to location so let's do
that so that when they go to a location
they they don't just keep like bobbling
around in there so they can actually
start to get work done so here there
they're going to location and then they
just sort of calm down and they they
take their spot and they sit there
really nice and if they're on a certain
tile I even have them lay of mine so
this is a neato thing that I thought of
is if you lay mines not in a fully dense
pattern then when the enemy attacks you
have the opportunity you have the
opportunity to sort of whittle them down
because you might have this
situation it's kind of hard to see on
this map I might take a screenshot and
then work on it so let's let's say that
we've got these mines here and that we
intend to use them in a really clever
way I mean yeah yeah so let's go here
soup elite soup elite so maybe the enemy
is coming this way now if they come here
they can either start to defuse the
mines and they'll be just waiting on
that corner or they can infiltrate
inside because it doesn't really present
a giant obstacle to them and once
they're in here I'm going to have a big
advantage because I can confront them
with a lot more area I think because
because they're all so sparsely laid out
so I think I think this will work really
well and if they want to retreat there's
definitely no way that's going to work
for them because they can't do any real
cycling in this configuration I think
it's going to totally mess them up so
here in this one I've got these guys who
are cleverly not there see they're not
gonna they're not going to defuse mines
in combat and they'll even sort of back
up and fight over the mines so here here
there they're backing up to the mines
and they're making sure they're trying
to they're trying to bring the fight you
know back back to home let's uh let's
show it with swarm one vs swarm three
because that that then they won't both
have that that part oh wait I was pretty
one sided ah right so this is this is
something that happens so here the enemy
is going to show up and I'm going to
retreat off the minefield and so then
they're sort of busy and then I come
back and I retreat a little bit more and
they they sort of start diffusing and
they think that's a good idea and then I
sort of you know go this back-and-forth
type motion and you know that kind of
thing can help to string out the enemies
in a line give me a little advantage but
even still you know it's not looking
that much that much like swarming now I
want to make the point that a lot of
these maps are absolutely filled with
with with these neutral minds especially
to begin with in this map you know
there's so many neutral minds to get
through
if you're really intelligent you could
take this path and I'll show an example
later of how you could write a player
that really efficiently paths through
the space for a whole whole mess of
troops so here I'm retreating past that
my little minefield and then I'm sort of
popping on forward again and he's sort
of poking the dragon here he's making me
irritated and and there and so then I'm
just gonna go kill him hmm but the
killing him was less effective than it
might have been because a lot of my guys
got stuck back there and they didn't
know what to do because i told i told
them please don't defuse mines in combat
and it was like combat because they were
going to attack the enemy headquarters
but nevertheless these guys got stuck so
what am I going to do well here's an
alternative where you could say each guy
has a certain amount of patience and if
he's stuck in one spot then he's going
to go ahead and and diffuse those mines
in combat so here once again this
pulling back and going forward strategy
is very effective against an equally
sized enemy these mine fields are a
wonderful defensive advantage that you
should definitely use so then here when
these guys get to get annoyed they can
start digging through and eventually
they'll make it through to the other
side which will be pretty which will be
pretty useful in in that case let's
let's do another example vs basic player
I think this example demonstrates that
that tunneling effect a little bit
better now basic player is building all
kinds of useful things like suppliers
and generators and that's going to make
him especially powerful so it's going to
be no actually I beat him so that's a
really good example let's uh let's move
on and i'm going to i'm going to try to
beat swarm for so swarm for was like
well maybe i'll maybe i'll continue
beating swarm one what i'm going to do
is I'm going to use guided swarm which
is a new player that I made so the new
this this guided swarms really neat this
is a lot more like birds and the guided
swarms goal is to his goal is to be a
little bit more puffy so his yeah that's
him up there look at him he's like all
cloud like and he's he's keeping it real
what a guy so you could see here that
like the guy the swarms kind of okay but
he's so spread out that
he doesn't do well in combat you know
what can we do to make this guidance
warm better what can we do I think one
thing that works really well is to put
them on a map that's better for him so
I'm going to I'm going to put them on
this one now he's a bit farther away
from the enemy and my hope is that he'll
have time to produce enough units that
he'll start laying a big minefield yes I
think I think that'll help him out
significantly oh come on please lay that
minefield please lay that minefield oh
we didn't have time to lay the minefield
I think I think what I'll do is I'll
tell them to build the minefield just a
little bit earlier I'm going to make
this right now I've got it don't let me
change the wrong code it's so easy to do
that you think robot player dot Java is
the code you're working on and it is but
you're wrong so I was working on guided
swarm one and I wanted it to be I want
the headquarters code to start building
these robots oh yeah I want him to
research pickaxe and once he's research
pickaxe I told him to tell the other
guys on channel plus one so here you
know you could you can use your get
channel function and then add one and
now you've got like sort of a set of
channels you can use so i'm going to i
want him to tell the others to please
start laying mines as soon as I have the
pickaxe upgrade alright so that's going
to happen I'll just make it at this
point and hopefully that'll give him
enough time to do it yeah so now he's
going to build fewer allied units before
he starts researching gosh this is a
tiny map if you can see this accurately
you don't need glasses yes that's
probably too i right so they started
laying mines and look at that pattern
look at the pattern they used oh my
goodness they must be somewhat skilled
can't believe that uh
but you see you see the point the point
that I made was that I found a really
neat way to make them lay mines in the
right pattern now now maybe you can't
really see that well so I'm going to
open up a good old-fashioned mathematica
not that good old fashioned Matt not
that good old fashioned there we go
Mathematica so you can see that this
arrangement this disposition of mind
positions which is like over 1 up to
your got to zoom in a little bit yeah if
you go over 1 up 2 over 1 up to this
arrangement is going to totally fill
space so this is where I've colored all
the adjacent ones in and this is going
to mean that if you lay mines at these
centers and you have the pickaxe upgrade
then you will be fully tiling space
really useful and here I'm going to give
away that the the trick you'll be on the
right spot if mod of 2 plus your ex Val
+ 1 x y or y val equals 5 or equals 0 if
mod this number 5 see if I change this
to like a seven then the whole pattern
changes and you can like investigate
different patterns by playing around
with it and these patterns may have
different effects depending on your
upgrades and the positioning of your
minds and you know it made me get a kind
of a neat idea so this is fully dense
you know and you could do partly dense
which is really simple you could just do
mod I plus J where I and J are your x
and y values you can just do mod 2 and
if that mod 2 is is equal to 1 then
that'll get you every other tile so no
matter where you are on the map you
don't have to start comparing to your
allied tile locations you don't have to
start doing a whole bunch of really
complicated operations just say if my
robot is on this nice tile then go ahead
and lay a mine really nice and here's a
really here's an interesting alternative
so this one is slightly farther spaced
apart than the one above this is sort of
like knights and chess where they can
move up and up and up or they could move
over and over and over well here I've
gone and done it a little bit farther
apart and the result is this neat-o
looking structured so it's like the the
one we did before where we had only done
a checkerboard pattern only now we have
a lot fewer minds to lay and we still
get sort of this interpenetrated mix
this could be really useful for fooling
the enemy team
the formula for this system is 3x plus
1y and as long as you mod that with
eight you'll get the you'll get the
answer you were looking for now this is
sort of an interesting system if I
change this to one I change this to five
I get the same result but sort of mirror
image it's a you know just playing
around with this kind of problem can be
quite enlightening if if you're not the
kind of person who instantly sees how
these systems work so let's let's do
like some summaries and then at the end
of the summaries i'm going to show you a
really awesome player a really amazing
version of this thing that has the
headquarters telling it where to go so
this is going to be at the very end of
lecture i'm going to show you it's the
same as this player that just lost this
match this one up here only instead of
being dumb when the enemy arrives it's
going to be smart about where it puts
itself with respect to the enemy which
is to say that it's going to avoid the
enemy unless the number of nearby allies
is a really high number and at the same
time the central headquarters is going
to tell it to capture encampments and to
build suppliers and generators on them
so you're going to start to have a
player that just from few little pieces
is starting to do everything that needs
to do to start to start winning matches
so I'll show that at the very end after
i summarize like some of the things that
I've done and some of the things that I
think you ought to try out because I can
put this code together in a certain
amount of time but I can't try every
possible combination so let's go
straight on over to here and I want to
just talk about two categories you know
let's talk about the shape of your
system which is to save the cloud let's
talk about how you achieve the shape and
you can achieve it either using a
headquarters and i'll talk about like
all the amazing things that you can have
the headquarter tell the group that you
might not have thought of and you can
achieve it using you know this this
group mind so let's uh let's do the
group mind first where you could check
the neighbors and go to the area with
the fewest i sent around some code i
don't know how many of you used it and
it looked
like this let me show you my lecture
three robot player release it's not
incredibly good code but you can see the
point so when these guys get close to
one another each one has this list and
this list shows the number of adjacent
enemy and allied units so that that list
is absolutely gosh darn tiny so I'm
going to go ahead and do a fancy way of
zooming in oh my goodness that's even
less legible that says 22 21 20 01 12 23
me 12 so me 12 means that I have two
allies adjacent and one enemy adjacent
and adjacent this number these are eight
different numbers indicating north north
west or north east east southeast and so
on around the clock directions although
not with 12 but with eight yeah and it
has this many enemies and this many
allies and so I've written the code for
you that'll do this and so the robot can
sort of start to make decisions about
who is adjacent to it all you've got to
do is sort of start sorting how good it
is to be next to allies or enemies like
maybe it's really good to be next to a
lot of allies and very few enemies or
otherwise you want to be close to few
allies so you spread out there are a lot
of things that you can sort of build on
that so that's why I that's why I
included that code so you could check
neighbors and go to the area with the
fewest you could compare to neighbor
repulsion so the repulsion is
accomplished in the following way so
I've written this this code here in
guided swarm and here's where you are
repelling from the enemies so this is
just one way of doing it a lot of ways
of doing it but I've called this
function frigo and it lets you sort of
like freely float among your various
alternatives of places to go what it
does is it says all right here I'm
starting at my location I'll get a
direction to the target location which
is like the Waypoint and now i'm going
to apply a target weight because baby i
really want to get there if i'm far away
but if i'm kind of close I don't really
care so now I have this function called
wait where if my distance squared is
greater than 100 I'll call the waiting
five if my distance squared is greater
than 9 i'll call the waiting too and if
i'm really close then I'll call the
waiting one so that's sort of giving me
this like spring like behavior to get to
where I want to go and it's going to
give me this gassy behavior so what I'll
do is I'll make a goal location which is
not the same as the target so that goal
location i'm going to just add to my
location this direction of the target so
let's let's do it on paint to give an
example because saying words is not
always incredibly clear so here's me
here's my my way point and maybe here's
the closest ally so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to repel from the ally and
I'm going to attract to the way point
which means I'm going to end up having a
bunch of guys that are having competing
requirements competing requirements is
like everything in these kinds of
dynamic systems because in the end
you'll want to expect them to find a
balance between these competing things
because frankly they want to do things
that are inconsistent they want to be at
the way point but they don't want to be
next to their friends so that
automatically means that they can't be
satisfied like a lot of people I know so
you can see here the repulsion term so
if the if there are allies then it will
locate the closest ally using this
function that I wrote very simple and
then it will add to the goal location
negative three of the direction to the
closest allies so what the heck does
that mean that's just saying repel if I
so my my goal location started here and
then I moved it toward the Waypoint some
amount and it would be more or less
depending on where the Waypoint was with
respect to me and now I'm going to take
the ally direction which is this
direction and i'm going to subtract that
from this so now i'm going away from the
ally and toward the way point which gets
me this X so in in the final analysis
this is my new goal location which is
the sum of a bunch of weighted added
directions and now I'm going to go that
way
which is going to get me both toward the
Waypoint and away from my Ally I mean on
a on a grid you know this direction may
have been quite close to or the same as
the direction directly to the way point
but when you keep doing it over and over
those little edge cases where a small
difference makes you go one way or the
other start to become significant and so
you can you can do it just simply like
this where you only care about whether
you know the ally that's closest is and
you only care about the weighting of the
of where you're going but wait just a
second there are so many things you can
add to it and that i did add when I
wrote my guided swarm to which is going
to end the lecture so let's do all the
let's do all the things that you can
repel or attract there's enemies and you
know you repel or attract to them based
on how many there are there's mines and
if they're yours you know do you want to
be right next to your minds you want to
be behind them do you want to be sort of
in a clump of them do you want to keep
laying my I mean if you're in a laying
mines mode then you don't really want to
stand on a mine because then you can't
lay one you're on one already so being
on your current goals so you can imagine
making the following this would be so
cool somebody in this room needs to do
this I was going to do it for today but
ran at a time is you do the following so
here's what always happens when I right
players is I've got a center and people
start laying mines around the center you
saw this I think you saw this today
where they were like laying these minds
and the mind sort of reached a certain
amount and the robots were only like out
to here and so that was it like you I
didn't get any more minds but here's
what you could do you could say halves
the headquarters which might be say down
here have it say if let's do this oh my
goodness watch this oh it's going to
work it's going to work headquarters if
there are a lot of minds in near the
rally point and it can do this very
easily you know how to do it there's a
really really handy function don't don't
do the following
here's what you were probably thinking
what you might have done is like sense
all the allied minds or whatever the
function name is and then like parse
through that list and find the ones that
are close to the Waypoint you don't have
to do that don't have to do that at all
you can see here in the documentation
under robot controller there's a method
that really helps there's sense mind
locations and it will tell it'll let you
specify a center a radius and a team so
let's put that on here so you definitely
want to be using this so that all you've
got to do is have the headquarters and
why would you use the headquarters just
so that it doesn't have to be done again
and again so the headquarters is going
to tell is going to say how many minds
are there when this X is the center and
I'm looking within some radius and you
could just expand the radius turn by
turn to see how many minds there are
until it starts to drop off or you could
just like set it at a given radius or
the previous radius so yeah let's let's
do it that way and you would say how
many of my minds are in this circle and
so you'd say if there are full minds in
the circle and you can do that pretty
easily because the circle is defined by
a radius squared right so expected minds
is like PI R squared right that's the
number of tiles but R squared we already
have and pi as an integer is equal to 3
and so we can just say the number of
expected minds equals 3 times the radius
squared and so that's also nice because
it's a little bit less than pi and so if
you're like mostly filled of mines in
that circle then so if if the detected
minds is greater than or equal to
expected mines in a full area then
expand the mind radius and you might say
well wait what am I am I expanding the
mine radius well here you go here you go
right now the function looks like this
for the repulsion and attraction it
looks like the following I'm oh I'm
going to use this yeah yeah like that so
if this is the distance X from Center
and this is the repulsive force or I
think
we were attracting yeah we were
attracting to the center the attractive
force was greater the farther you got
from the center but you could imagine so
that's going to push everybody toward
the middle but you don't have to do that
you could just as easily have the
headquarters the headquarters is telling
everybody could could be telling
everybody about by message systems what
this looks like and they could very well
tell them to make it a little bit more
like this so let's say that you already
put mines out to this range so you've
got you've already put mines here and
you've detected them using the
headquarters so now you want everybody
to show up here well you could very
simply do that all you've got to do is
make the forces look like this what kind
of oh wow is that right no we would want
that yeah yeah well that's the energy
and the force is this yeah the
attractive force is this so this is
exactly a spring it's a spring from
physics and that will make them go
toward it if they are inside because
they will go opposite the direction of
this vector from the from the origin and
they'll make it go away if they're in
the other direction and you get the idea
so that's that's a pretty neat idea
because you can have them spread out in
a circle and sort of maintain that you
know that sort of positional Authority
as it were very very cool we are we are
also going to talk about some other
awesome things the headquarter can tell
them even though our mouths are watering
check check the neighbors okay we can
avoid this we can avoid we can avoid
minds we can avoid the enemy to do those
things there's no more direction we've
talked about that so now let's now let's
go back a little bit and talk about how
the headquarters can help you achieve a
given shape the headquarters can can
signal when the enemy has artillery now
how's the headquarters going to know
well it could it could receive the
message from somebody else that notices
his hit points have dropped by 20 or 40
or it could just like locate and
artillery like if you actually
physically walk past one then you could
say there are just an artillery there I
should start repelling my other units
like they should start spreading out
because if they are all clumped together
they're going to take a lot more
damage they're going to take instead of
40 damage for just one hit they're going
to take eight splash damage as well and
so that's going to end up being an
additional five times worse yeah let's
go well it's going to be four times
worse from five times as bad as it were
that's that's definitely no good so yeah
that's one I mean that's that's how like
you're changing the shape of your cloud
using using the communication that
you're giving from the headquarters or
from somewhere else so you could do that
you can you can say when the group and
you could say like average position has
arrived at a waypoint like a waypoint
that the headquarters has specified then
go to the next one and right there you
know you can start to fill the whole map
that way now this is a really crazy
trick that I think is what is the bee's
knees and it's just going to make the
difference between amazing code and non
amazing code so everybody is going to
have have this situation and I've had
this situation for a long time but I
very rarely in fact I've never come up
with a solution until just recently and
it was the following okay so here's me
here's me and here's the goal okay i
want to go from one to the other and a
lot of times what happens is you know
I've got a large group of people and
they end up splatting they just splat
and then they trickle like this is a
little thin line of trickle of units and
everybody else is just splatting there
and they're there they're really unhappy
yeah it's no good it's it's I think I
think this guy here is like gone to
sleep and it's it's just I mean this guy
like started to tunnel and so he's like
mining in there and then when like these
guys arrived he's like I don't know I'm
tired I'm going on workers strike so I
mean it's just terrible so here's here's
an alternative to that that mate that
may make the difference between winning
and losing that may be like this may
just become the dominant strategy I
couldn't be more infatuated with my idea
and it works like this works like this
where I'd say okay okay I'm I'm
headquarters I'm headquarters back here
and I'm telling them what to do all I've
got to do is look here here and here and
I can use the sense the sense new
mine's i'll use the sense neutral minds
and I'll put these as the centers one
two three four okay 50 these are and
this is these are the directions that
the whole swarm could move and I'll say
okay this has seven minds and this says
to know this isn't realistic they all
have zero okay they all have zero right
but then once I move down a little bit
come on paint come on paint help me out
here okay now I move down a little bit
and now some directions really look bad
so what I can do is tell the whole swarm
to follow a waypoint set that looks like
a giant robot not like a Gundam know
like like a like one unit of robot so
like the whole swarm becomes one big
thing that can all paths around the
object because I've downsampled the
terrain now I mean this down sampling
idea can extend to full search full
search and padding algorithms I mean
yeah you'd split it up like this or so
something like this they can be
overlapping or non overlapping down
sample boxes you can use blur or other
features is you know standard concepts
in computer science so that you can
start to do pathing on a much simpler
matrix and this can get you to your
enemy like leagues faster than you would
otherwise get and if you use a heuristic
then does it even matter if there's like
let's say there's like a few mines here
well maybe you'll just bear oh right on
through I mean it's if you can just
compared to the amount of minds that
you're going to find here versus here
like what better way to make that
comparison then to count mines in a
giant area like this and these giant
areas are going to be so computationally
simple for you to compute because it's
just one function call and I believe
that function call only cost you like a
hundred dollars and buy dollars i mean
byte codes so this has been a summary of
a bunch of types of swarm but it hasn't
been a complete summary yet has it
because i told you i was going to show
you that amazing code that I wrote and
this time I may or may not be being
facetious and that amazing code where
I've made this guided swarm too and I'm
going to play it against a basic player
on maybe a couple of maps basic player
is not horrible I guess I don't really
know how good or bad we're expecting to
claim that it is but let's go ahead and
show this match so here I've got guided
swarm in red okay and it's
starting out by building a checker port
of checker brick checkerboard pattern of
Mines when he's going to do is when he
encounters the enemy he sometimes gonna
just rush straight at the enemy other
times he's going to sort of backup and
then only fight at the right time in
this example it looks like he was
destroyed up well the enemy built
artillery right next to my base that
doesn't count ok ok this one here i am
down in the bottom left i'm gonna get
ready to research pickaxe I'm gonna do
it and then when I research pickaxe
their mining pattern is going to change
they're gonna they're going to spread
out i think or maybe I didn't I might
not have implemented it well in any case
it's there so it sort of exists in my
mind that i'll do that sometime so what
I'll do is when they when they arrive
here I'll totally mess them up you know
they're going to show up I'll back up
just a little bit and then they're going
to be on my mind and they're gonna have
nothing to say about it they're gonna
have thicken it just they're gonna be
they're gonna oh so there I go there go
I'm starting up and starting to move out
start to continue to build mines and I'm
gone forward um I don't know that I
think he doesn't have really any robots
yeah yeah super effective oh my goodness
that was fantastic I'm I'm actually
going to do I wonder I wonder if it is
working as I was expecting so in this
one I'm going across and when the enemy
shows up I hope what I'm hoping is it
already ended yes I'm hoping to sort of
back up just a little bit and then and
then take them on no it looks like I
just run straight in well it won't any
case you know I sort of spread out i
made this neat little pattern i'm
starting to take these encampments you
know it's getting done I'm doing it up
making it happen I take the other side I
take more encampments and then I just
sort of procedures these are like now
I've got better production than he has
I'm going to cast I'm going to cast
these games this well when we have the
finals it's gonna be great so we have
yeah I'm making more units oh look at
this look at this you see this see this
like micro I'm backing up a little bit
you know letting them let them do it I'm
doing some micro here making sure that I
outnumber the enemy before I go in you
know not I'm not keeping it so spread
out as I was before some guys are doing
some important philosophy
and you know those philosophical results
just very well may make the difference
between you know our salvation as a
species and not thank you very much for
attending the swarm lecture next lecture
will be about strategy and I hope you
enjoyed the Indian food